>> Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SOME OF THE GIRLS WERE
RELUCTANT TO GET MAKEOVERS.
>> Robin: IT'S KIND OF LIKE
JUST HAVING, LIKE, HAIR COLOR
FROM H-E-DOUBLE HOCKEY STICKS.
>> Tyra: A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
NEARLY KNOCKED ADRIANNE
OUT OF THE COMPETITION.
EBONY LEARNED HOW TOUGH
THE CRITICISM CAN GET.
THE TEXTURE OF YOUR SKIN
NEEDS A LOT OF WORK.
BUT IN THE END, IT WAS NICOLE
WHO WAS SENT PACKING.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
>> Jon: GOOD MORNING!
HELLO!
GUESS WHO'S HERE!
WAKE UP.
WAKE UP! WAKE UP!
IT'S TIME TO WORK OUT.
YES. COME ON!
WE'RE LEAVING IN A HALF-HOUR.
>> Elyse: JON THE TRAINER
IS SUPPOSED TO, UM,
WHIP US ALL INTO SHAPE.
>> Jon: HELLO!
OH, YEAH! IT'S TIME TO GO!
COME ON! NO GOING BACK TO BED!
>> Giselle: THE LAST ELIMINATION
WAS THE WORST FOR ME.
>> Tyra: GISELLE, IF YOU DON'T
THINK YOU'RE FIERCE,
IF YOU DON'T THINK YOU'RE HOT,
YOU DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE GREAT,
THEN I WON'T.
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM?
YEAH, RIGHT.
>> Jon: 3, 4, 5.
SO LEFT LEG UP
AND LEFT LEG BACK.
REVERSE ONE MORE TIME.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
FIRST HOLD 'EM OUT THERE.
>> Adrianne: I BUST MY BALLS
HERE EVERY WEEK.
I TELL MYSELF EVERY WEEK
THAT I'M GONNA BE
THE LAST ONE STANDING.
>> Jon: ADRIANNE HAD ISSUES
TODAY WITH STOMACH PROBLEMS.
SHE HAD FOOD POISONING,
SO HER LEVEL OF COMMITMENT--
JUST BEING THERE--
WAS IMPRESSIVE.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: SUPPOSED TO MAKE
MY SKIN FABULOUS.
THE JUDGES BASICALLY TOLD ME
THAT MY SKIN WAS NOT GOOD.
I GOT IT, GIRL.
I'LL WORK ON IT.
IT WILL BE FLAWLESS.
♪♪♪
>> Giselle: EBONY--SHE'S...
SHE USES SO MUCH GREASE
ON HERSELF THAT, LIKE,
HER GREASE
GETS ON THE DOORKNOBS,
IN THE BATHROOM.
SHE'S SO... LOUD.
>> Ebony: YOU THINK, HEY!
YOU GET UP ON YOUR BOOTY
AND YOU MOVE IT!
OH, YEAH, HE'S SO HOT.
MAKES ME BUBBLE RIGHT INSIDE.
>> Shannon: I THINK EACH WEEK IS
DEFINITELY A NEW PLAYING FIELD
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE, UM,
A DIFFERENT TASK,
SO SOME MAY EXCEL IN THIS AREA,
AND SOME MAY EXCEL IN THAT AREA.
SO THINGS COULD CHANGE
MOST DEFINITELY.
♪♪♪
>> Giselle: TYRA MAIL TOLD US
TO BE DOWNSTAIRS IN THE LOBBY.
WE DID NOT KNOW
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
DO YOU GUYS KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE TODAY?
>> Robin: NO, MA'AM.
>> Giselle: SOME SORT OF
THEATER.
>> Tyra: SOME SORT OF THEATER.
WELL, YOU GUYS ARE
IN AN ACTING SCHOOL--
ONE OF THE PREMIER
ACTING SCHOOLS IN NEW YORK CITY,
AND I HAVE BROUGHT IN A WOMAN
BY THE NAME OF ALICE SPIVAK.
ALICE IS A PREMIER ACTING COACH,
AND SHE HAS TAUGHT
A LOT OF DIFFERENT MODELS.
SHE'S TAUGHT CLAUDIA SCHIFFER,
CINDY CRAWFORD AND JAIME KING.
WE'RE NOT HERE TODAY
TO TEACH YOU GUYS HOW TO BE
ACTRESSES FOR A MOVIE.
WE'RE HERE TO TEACH YOU HOW
TO INCORPORATE IT INTO MODELING.
I THINK ACTING'S
VERY IMPORTANT WITH MODELING,
ESPECIALLY WITH
SELLING PRODUCTS.
NOW ALICE IS GOING TO DO
ACTING EXERCISES WITH YOU
TO LOOSEN YOU UP,
AND LATER THIS WEEK,
YOU'LL BE TESTED
ON YOUR ABILITIES.
ALL RIGHT, Y'ALL, ALICE SPIVAK,
COME ON OUT.
>> Alice: (laughing)
I WAS THINKING OF DOING
AN IMAGINARY LITTLE SCENE
MAYBE WRAPPED AROUND AN OBJECT.
AN OBJECT IN ACTING IS A PROP,
AND ALSO AN OBJECT CAN BE
ANOTHER PERSON, A LIVING OBJECT.
EBONY'S ALL EXCITED
BECAUSE SHE CAN'T WAIT TO GO.
♪♪♪
>> Alice: I CHOSE TO BEGIN WITH
JUST WILD IMPROVISATIONAL WORK,
GIVING THEM A BASIC GROUNDWORK
FOR ACTING.
>> Elyse: I'VE NEVER DONE
ANY ACTING EXCEPT FOR
THE FABULOUS PRODUCTION
"BLACK ELK SPEAKS"
IN SEVENTH GRADE.
>> Alice: ELYSE REALLY NEEDED
TO OPEN UP, AND SHE OPENED UP
A LITTLE AT A TIME.
NOW THE SECOND PERSON
WHO COMES IN BRINGS IN
THE RELATIONSHIP.
SO, SHANNON, YOU BETTER
GET OVER HERE,
BECAUSE SHE'S STARTING ALREADY.
>> Adrianne: WHOOSH!
>> Kesse: THIS IS NOT ABOUT ME.
IT'S ABOUT YOU, THINKIN'
YOU ALL THAT, AND YOU NOT.
>> Ebony: ARE YOU USING THOSE
COLGATE STRIPS?
YOU'RE NOT USING THE COLGATE
STRIPS
THAT I GOT YOU, HONEY.
>> Elyse: MY GOD.
SIT DOWN, GISELLE.
>> Giselle: I'M SEEING MICE,
GIRL.
>> Alice: SHANNON NEEDS TO
TAKE IT MORE SERIOUSLY.
I WAS WATCHING
AND FELT A REAL PROGRESSION
GOING ON WITH THE GIRLS.
AND GISELLE IS REALLY
VERY GOOD, REALLY.
ROBIN SURPRISED ME
IN HER TOTAL FREEDOM.
BUT WHO MOVED ME IN TERMS OF
BEING PRIVATE AND BEING
IN THE MOMENT WAS EBONY.
>> Shannon: WELL, THANK YOU.
>> Alice: YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Shannon: WE'LL SEE YOU
TOMORROW.
>> Alice: YES.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: FOR MODELS
FIRST STARTING OUT,
LIVING SPACE IS AT A PREMIUM.
SO WITH THREE GIRLS
ALREADY GONE, I HAD THE GIRLS
FROM THE MIAMI ROOM
MOVE INTO THE TOKYO ROOM
TO KEEP IT REAL.
>> Adrianne: EVERYONE'S LIKE,
"SO YOU'RE MOVING OUT OF MIAMI
INTO TOKYO NOW, RIGHT?"
AND I WAS LIKE, HUH?
>> Robin: WHEN THEY MOVED OUT,
IT JUST FEELS LIKE, UM,
MISS KESSE AND MISS SHANNON NOW.
WE HAVE THE WHOLE SIDE
TO OURSELVES NOW.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
GOD IS GOOD.
>> Giselle: WHEN WE FOUND OUT
THAT EBONY AND ADRIANNE
WERE MOVING INTO OUR ROOM,
WE WERE LIKE, "OKAY, WHATEVER,"
BUT I WAS EXCITED TO HEAR
THAT ADRIANNE WAS MOVING IN.
IT WAS OKAY THAT EBONY
WAS MOVING IN, 'CAUSE WE HADN'T
HAD ANY KIND OF PROBLEMS YET.
(sighs)
>> J.: HEY.
>> Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN'?!
>> Robin: WHAT'D HE SAY?
>> J.: WHAT'S GOIN' ON?
>> Shannon: WHAT YOU DOIN'?
>> Robin: DON'T WE LOOK FABULOUS
TONIGHT?
>> Elyse: J. ALEXANDER
SURPRISED AS AT THE HOUSE.
EVERYONE WAS IN THEIR PAJAMAS,
AND SO READY TO GO TO SLEEP.
>> Shannon: J. CAME IN,
AND HE IS THE RUNWAY EXPERT,
TOTALLY.
AND J.'s BEEN WORKING WITH US
ON OUR WALK.
HE CAN WORK THAT RUNWAY.
>> Adrianne: I THINK
J. ALEXANDER IS THE BOMB.
I THINK HE IS SUCH A DIVA.
>> Robin: I GOTTA REST.
>> J.: WELL, WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE WALKING LESSON
BEFORE YOU START RESTING, BABY.
I JUST WANNA SEE, YOU KNOW,
JUST, LIKE, WHERE YOU GUYS
SORT OF, LIKE, LEFT OFF
AND WHERE YOU PICKED UP.
♪♪♪
>> J.: MISS EBONY, BABY...
I NEED LONG STEPS.
LET ME STAND NEXT TO YOU.
GIRL!
YOU ABOUT TO BE FRIED.
YOU ARE.
>> All: (laughing)
>> J.: YOU ABOUT TO BE...
>> J.: YOU ARE ABOUT TO BE
FRIED.
>> Ebony: THAT'S JUST...
I WAS GOING THROUGH ISSUES,
SO I'M, YOU KNOW, MOISTURIZING.
>> J.: WHOA, BABY, WHAT KIND OF
ISSUES WAS YOU GOING THROUGH
THAT YOU'RE MOISTURIZING?
>> Ebony: I DON'T KNOW. I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S NO SLEEP.
IT'S NO, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW...
>> Elyse: THERE WAS GREASE
ALL OVER BECAUSE OF HER NEW
MOISTURIZING REGIME.
UGH.
>> Robin: BEFORE YOU GO,
WE GOTTA ASK YOU A QUESTION.
CAN YOU BE A CELEBRITY JUDGE
IN OUR BA-DONKA-DONK CONTEST
RIGHT QUICK?
BA-DONKA-DONK IS A DANCE.
♪ SHAKE THAT BOOTY ♪
♪ SHAKING THAT BUTT ♪
♪ BOOTY BANGIN' ♪
♪ YOU KNOW I LOVE IT ♪
♪ AIN'T NO OTHER WAY ♪
♪ TO EXPLAIN IT ♪
♪ THE WAY I'M-A THROW IT ♪
♪ IN THE CLUB ♪
♪ I SEE THEM CHICKS... ♪
>> Elyse: EVERYBODY GETS
TOGETHER
AND SHAKES THEIR DONK-DONKS,
UM, FOR A PRIZE.
I DON'T THINK I'M GONNA
PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
♪ COME ON, WE AT THE CLUB ♪
♪ EVERYBODY BOOTY BANGIN' ♪
♪ SAY WHAT? ♪
>> Shannon: IT'S NOT JUST A
SHAKE. IT'S A SWIVEL.
SO YOU GOTTA GET, LIKE,
THE SWIVEL INTO IT.
♪ TO THE LEFT, TO THE RIGHT ♪
♪ EVERYBODY BOOTY BANGIN'... ♪
>> Kesse: DONK-DONK IS
SOMETHING THAT I REALLY, REALLY
LIKE TO DO, AND THAT'S DANCE.
♪ AFTER THEY DONE ♪
♪ SHAKE YOUR BUTT ♪
♪ COME ON ♪
♪ BE AT THE CLUB ♪
♪ EVERYBODY BOOTY BANGIN'... ♪
>> J.: GIRL...
♪ LET ME SEE YOU ♪
♪ SHAKE YOUR THANG ♪
♪ GO ON AND SHAKE IT ♪
♪ FROM THE LEFT TO THE RIGHT ♪
♪ EVERYBODY... ♪
>> Elyse: KESSE IS HILARIOUS.
SHE GOES TO CHURCH,
AND SHE'S PART OF THE HOLY ROOM,
AND YET SHE DOES DIRTY DANCING.
♪ YOU KNOW THE FLOW ♪
♪ LET ME SEE THEM... ♪♪
>> J.: DANG.
YOU WENT TO PICK UP A QUARTER.
>> Robin: KESSE'S
THE OFFICIAL DIVA OF THE HOUSE.
EVERYBODY GIVE KESSE
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
>> Adrianne: THE ONLY REASON
I DIDN'T WIN IS
I DIDN'T DO THE SPLITS,
WHICH I DON'T SEE HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE BUTT.
I NEED A TISSUE. MAN!
>> Adrianne: NO!
>> Adrianne: WHAT IS SHE
GONNA TELL HER?
GISELLE SAID THAT SHE WAS GONNA
TELL EBONY TO WASH HER HANDS
BEFORE SHE TOUCHES ANYTHING.
SO I CAN'T WAIT FOR THE, UM,
GISELLE VERSUS EBONY
ANTI-GREASE SHOWDOWN.
I SINCERELY HOPE TO BE THERE.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: THESE PEOPLE
LIVE LIKE PIGS.
I VACUUM. I LOAD THE DISHWASHER.
THE HOUSE LOOKS LIKE CRAP.
>> Robin: IT'S NASTY.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
THAT DON'T CLEAN UP
BEHIND THEMSELVES, AND, UM,
IT BECOMES A PROBLEM
FOR THE WHOLE HOUSE.
OUR SIDE IS CLEAN.
>> Adrianne: THE WONDERFUL
CHRISTIANS THAT, YOU KNOW,
THINK THEY'RE BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY
AND THEY'RE HOLIER THAN THOU--
I CLEAN UP THEIR MESSES
ALL THE TIME.
♪♪♪
>> Giselle: ELYSE.
>> Elyse: GISELLE REALLY
SET THE PRECEDENT FOR LAZINESS
WITH HER CONSTANT SLEEPING
AND UNWILLINGNESS TO EXERT
THE EFFORT TO GO AND GET HERSELF
A BOWL OF LUCKY CHARMS
IN THE MORNING.
>> Kesse: I DON'T THINK SHE'S
USED TO PULLING HER WEIGHT.
I THINK SHE'S USED
TO PEOPLE CLEANING UP
BEHIND HER.
>> Ebony: SHE CAN BE
A LITTLE ANNOYING, BUT SHE'S 18.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> Giselle: WE HAVE TO ACT
TODAY.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: ALICE CAME OVER AGAIN,
AND WE HAD A COMPETITION.
>> Alice: YESTERDAY WAS
A BIG LEARNING DAY,
AND ALSO TODAY IS
A CHALLENGE DAY.
I'M SELECTING SOMEBODY
ON THE BASIS OF THE EFFORT
AND THE DESIRE,
AND THE AWARD IS
A SPA TREATMENT.
>> Shannon: NO!
>> Alice: AND THAT
AWARD WINNER--
>> Shannon: CAN PICK TWO?
>> Alice: CAN SELECT TWO OTHERS.
>> Ebony: THE REWARD WAS
GOING TO GET YOUR NAILS DONE,
GETTING A MESSAGE, AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL WANT,
WE ALL NEED.
>> Alice: AND THE OTHER FOUR,
YOU HAVE TO CLEAN UP THIS PLACE.
>> Giselle: WELL,
THIS IS GONNA BE GREAT.
I'M GONNA GET STUCK CLEANING.
>> Alice: THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
TODAY.
SO IT'S HARD WHEN
IT'S COLD READING,
AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK UP,
BUT IT'S OKAY, TOO,
'CAUSE I WANNA SEE JUST HOW MUCH
YOU CAN USE THE COPY
AND LOOK UP AND TALK
AND LOOK BACK DOWN.
SO WHO WANTS TO READ COLD?
GISELLE.
>> Giselle: JUST READ IT?
>> Alice: JUST READ COLD.
>> Giselle: "I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT JIM BROKE UP WITH ME--
WITH ME.
I KNEW I SHOULD HAVE
BROKEN UP WITH HIM FIRST."
>> Alice: I THINK THAT GISELLE
IS THE MOST WORRIED
ABOUT DOING AS WELL OR BETTER.
>> Shannon: "I KNEW I SHOULDN'T
HAVE BROKEN UP WITH HIM FIRST."
(imitates crying)
"I HATE CRYING.
I REFUSE TO CRY.
MY EYES JUST GET WAY TOO PUFFY."
>> Alice: SHANNON--
SHE KINDA JUMPS IN,
DIVES IN, SPLASHES AROUND A BIT,
AND MAYBE IT'LL COME OUT
ALL RIGHT.
>> Adrianne: "I WISH I COULD CRY
THE WAY AUDREY HEPBURN DID
IN 'BREAKFAST AT TIFFANY'S.'
IT WAS SO CUTE."
>> Alice: ADRIANNE WAS SOFTER,
SMILING, AND, UH,
SHE BECAME RELAXED,
ALMOST LIKE A PROFESSIONAL.
>> Elyse: "I WISH
MY EYES WERE BIGGER.
MAYBE I COULD ARCH
MY EYEBROWS MORE."
>> Alice: ELYSE, I THINK,
IS A REALLY LOVELY GIRL.
SHE CAN REALLY DO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
SHE CAN BE STRONG.
SHE CAN ALSO GET EMOTIONAL.
>> Kesse: "WHAT DOES HE KNOW
ANYWAY?
HE THINKS HE'S SO SMART
BECAUSE HE'S A BRAIN SURGEON."
>> Alice: KESSE IS WANTING
TO DO IT.
HER TENDENCY IS
TO PUSH TOO HARD.
>> Ebony: "WHAT DOES HE MEAN,
I'M SELF-CENTERED?
MY YOGA INSTRUCTOR SAYS THAT
THE CENTER OF YOURSELF
IS WHERE I NEED TO BE."
>> Alice: IT'S GONNA BE HARD
WITH EBONY.
SHE'S VERY AGGRESSIVE,
AND SHE'S VERY FRUSTRATED,
WHICH CAN MAKE HER VERY ANGRY.
>> Robin: "I NEED TO BLEACH
MY TEETH.
THEY'RE GETTING SO YELLOW.
OH, MY GOSH.
MY TEETH ARE YELLOW,
MY EYEBROWS ARE BUSHY
AND MY EYES ARE BEADY.
NO WONDER HE BROKE UP WITH ME.
I GOTTA GET HIM BACK."
>> Alice: ROBIN TURNED
INTO THE MOST SURPRISING.
SHE REALLY CAN ACT.
SO YOU ALL DID SO WELL,
BUT I WILL GIVE THE AWARD
TO ROBIN.
>> Shannon: YAY!
>> Giselle: WHAT'S FUNNY
IS THAT ROBIN WON THAT
ACTING CHALLENGE,
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT,
AND MADE IT SEEM LIKE
SHE WAS THE BIG ACTRESS
OF THE BUNCH.
>> Alice: ROBIN WILL PICK
HER TWO.
>> Robin: MY PICK--
MISS SHANNON AND MISS KESSE.
>> Elyse: IT WOULDN'T HAVE
REALLY HAVE BEEN AN AWARD FOR ME
TO GET MY NAILS DONE.
I'M SURE I JUST WOULD HAVE
CHIPPED 'EM ANYWAY IMMEDIATELY.
BUT I WASN'T NECESSARILY
LOOKING FORWARD
TO CLEANING THE HOUSE.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: I'M NOT LIVING
LIKE A PIG ANYMORE.
I CAN'T TAKE IT.
MY HOUSE IS IMMACULATE.
JUST LIKE, BLING, BLING,
BLING, BLING, BLING!
AND I COME HERE,
AND IT'S LIKE...
(imitates splattering sounds)
>> Giselle: EBONY,
COULD YOU DO ONE FAVOR?
JUST THIS ONE FAVOR?
AND I DON'T--I HOPE IT'S NOT,
LIKE, NOT A BAD THING
OR ANYTHING.
AFTER YOU PUT THE, UM,
YOUR STUFF ON,
COULD YOU MAKE SURE YOU, LIKE,
THOROUGHLY CLEAN YOUR HANDS?
JUST BECAUSE IT GETS
ON THE DOORKNOBS,
AND IT'S, LIKE, SLIPPERY.
>> Ebony: UM...
OKAY, I'LL TRY TO CONCENTRATE
ON THAT.
>> Giselle: JUST THAT. THAT'S
ALL I HAVE A PROBLEM--
I MEAN, I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
IT'S A REAL BIG PROBLEM
THAT'S ALL, AND IT'S NOT OR
ANYTHING.
IN A BAD WAY AT ALL--LIKE AT
ALL.
♪♪♪
>> Kesse: INSTEAD OF US
HAVING TO GO TO THE SPA,
THE SPA CAME TO US,
WHILE THE OTHER FOUR GIRLS
HAD TO CLEAN.
>> Shannon: LOOK HOW GOOD
HER NAILS LOOK.
IT'S, LIKE,
RELEASED ALL THIS TENSION.
ARE THEY CLEANING
OUR BATHROOM, TOO?
>> Kesse: THEY HAD
THE MASSAGE TABLE IN TOKYO,
WHERE THEY HAD TO SEE IT
WHILE THEY WERE CLEANING.
IT WAS SO MEAN.
>> Ebony: THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
LEFT TO CLEAN THE HOUSE
WERE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN CLEANING THE HOUSE.
>> Giselle: (humming)
>> Ebony: EXCEPT FOR GISELLE.
GISELLE'S SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Giselle: OW!
OH!
>> Kesse: EBONY, ADRIANNE
AND ELYSE WERE, LIKE, SCRUBBIN',
DOIN' FLOORS, WINDOWS.
SHE WASN'T DOING ANYTHING.
>> Giselle: I HAVE A QUESTION.
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF, LIKE,
IF WE'RE DONE, IN BETWEEN GIRLS,
I COULD SIT JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW, OR JUST STAND REALLY
QUICK JUST LIKE THIS,
AND YOU COULD JUST GO LIKE THAT?
>> Man: I COULD DO THAT.
>> Giselle: OH, MY GOD!
>> Ebony: WHEN SHE SAID THAT,
I BLURTED OUT, "YOU KNOW, HEY,
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOTTA BE
KIDDING ME."
WELL, SHE GOT UPSET. YES, HONEY.
>> Giselle: YOU'RE SITTING HERE.
I ASKED HIM A QUESTION.
YOU'RE LIKE, "ARE YOU KIDDING
ME? ARE YOU KIDDING ME?"
>> Ebony: I'M NOT TALKING TO
YOU. YOU KNOW WHAT?
I CANNOT HELP YOUR IMMATURITY.
I AM SORRY.
NOBODY'S GONNA LIKE YOU.
>> Giselle: NO, NO, SERIOUSLY,
YOU'RE DOING THAT STUPID AGE
THING AGAIN.
>> Ebony: WHAT STUPID AGE THING?
>> Giselle: YOU BRING UP THE
AGE.
>> Ebony: I'M NOT GOING THROUGH
IT. SWEETIE, I'M NOT GOING
THROUGH IT WITH YOU.
>> Giselle: I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND. I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> Ebony: I'M NOT GONNA GO
THROUGH IT WITH YOU.
>> Giselle: I NEED TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
>> Ebony: I AM SORRY. THERE'S
NOTHING YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT.
I TREAT YOU THE SAME WAY
I TREAT THIS YOUNG LADY HERE.
I TREAT EVERYBODY THE SAME EXACT
WAY. YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE YOU'RE ASKING FOR
MASSAGES WHILE WE'RE CLEANING UP
INSTEAD OF CLEANING THE TUB
LIKE YOU SAID YOU WERE GONNA DO.
>> Giselle: YOU'RE MY ROOMMATE,
AND I NEED TO GET ALONG WITH
MY ROOMMATES, AND I DON'T
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU HAVE TO
ACT LIKE THAT TOWARDS ME.
>> Ebony: YOU KNOW WHAT,
SWEETIE?
GO AND TALKTO SOMEBODY ELSE
ABOUT IT,
BUT DON'T DO IT WITH ME.
BECAUSE I'M VERY INTELLIGENT,
AND I'M NOT GONNA PLAY
THIS LITTLE GAME WITH YOU.
>> Giselle: SHE WAS LIKE,
"THIS IS SO IMMATURE.
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA TALK
ABOUT IT ANYMORE," BUT THEN, OH,
OKAY, MISS MATURE WOMAN,
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T WANNA TALK
ABOUT IT, BUT YET SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH ADRIANNE.
>> Adrianne: I'M MISSING A LOT
OF EVERYTHING, 'CAUSE I WASN'T
LISTENING TO ANYTHING.
>> Ebony: GISELLE SAID THAT SHE
WAS GOING TO CLEAN THE BATHROOM.
SHE WENT IN THERE AND STARTED--
>> Adrianne: I DIDN'T HEAR THAT
EITHER BUT--
>> Ebony: OKAY, BUT ANYWAY,
THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE SAID.
I'M BEING NICE BY SAYING THAT.
PUT IT LIKE THIS. SHE WAS
IN THE BATHROOM CLEANING,
AND I ASSUME THAT'S WHAT
SHE WAS DOING. SHE'S DONE
THINGS LIKE THAT BEFORE WHERE
SHE DID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THAT'S IMMATURITY. I HAVE
NO TIME FOR THAT. I'M BAFFLED.
I'M BAFFLED. I GOT GARBAGE
TO PUT AWAY. EXCUSE ME.
>> Adrianne: I DON'T CARE.
>> Ebony: THAT 18-YEAR-OLD--
ME TRYING TO BE, YOU KNOW,
A GREAT ROLE MODEL AND ALL THAT,
IT NEEDS TO CUT AT ONE POINT.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
I'M NOT HERE TO BE A ROLE MODEL.
I'M HERE ON A COMPETITION.
>> Giselle: "THIS IS
A COMPETITION.
THIS IS A COMPETITION."
IT'S LIKE, WE'RE IN THE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW.
WOULD YOU CALM DOWN
WITH THE DAMN COMPETITION?
>> Ebony: EXCUSE ME.
THAT'S FINE WITH YOU.
THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
BUT I SEE MY SITUATION WITH YOU,
I SEE IT--LET ME FINISH FIRST.
I'LL LET YOU FINISH.
>> Giselle: YOU KNOW, WE TRY
TO SAY SOMETHING, AND OHH!
SHE HAS TO, LIKE, BARK
OVER YOUR VOICE,
AND IT'S SO FRICKIN' ANNOYING.
>> Ebony: YOU FEEL LIKE
I'M OVERBEARING YOU IN TALKING,
BUT THAT'S ON YOU
FOR NOT SAYING NOTHING.
BUT I'M NOT HERE TO EXPLAIN--
>> Giselle: BUT I CAN'T. THAT'S
MY PROBLEM.
>> Ebony: THAT'S ON YOU.
THAT'S ON YOU, BABY.
YOU HAVE TO WORK THAT OUT,
AND I CAN'T HELP THAT.
I CAN,THOUGH.
>> Elyse: IT WAS A
QUINTESSENTIALLY EBONY-ESQUE
FREAK-OUT.
>> Ebony: I HAVE NOTHING ELSE
REALLY TO SAY.
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
YOU WANTED TO SAY TO ME?
FABULOUS.
YOU WANNA SAY SOMETHING, GIRL,
YOU GOT A MOUTH.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY USE IT.
NOW I'M GOING TO FINISH
MY STRAWBERRY SHORTCAKE
OR WHATEVER IT IS--CHEESECAKE.
WORK IT OUT.
I DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY
GISELLE HANDLED THE SITUATION.
YOU KNOW, I FELT AS THOUGH
SHE HAS THE TENDENCY TO TAKE
THINGS VERY PERSONAL.
>> Giselle: AT THIS POINT,
I REALLY DON'T EVEN CARE
ANYMORE.
I'M NOT GONNA GO
OUT OF CONTROL HERE,
BECAUSE I CAN, BUT I WON'T.
AND... (sighs)
>> Ebony: SHE'S YOUNG. SHE
DOESN'T REALIZE THE CONSEQUENCES
OF WHAT SHE DOES.
UM, I THINK SHE HAS NO CLUE.
BUT I'M JUST GONNA BE MYSELF.
THAT'S THE BEST I CAN DO.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: SO... UM, I'M SORRY,
GUYS, THAT I HAD ALL OF YOU
COME IN HERE, BUT I WANTED
TO KNOW IF IT'S OKAY IF
MY GIRLFRIEND COULD COME OVER
FOR ABOUT AN HOUR OR TWO TODAY.
TONIGHT.
>> Robin: EBONY'S A LESBIAN,
AND I FOUND THIS OFFENSIVE,
BUT I CANNOT PASS JUDGMENT
ON HER.
I JUST KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE
THAT PROCLAIM THAT, YOU KNOW,
THEY LOVE THE LORD
AND ARE CHRISTIANS, YOU KNOW,
ARE NOT ALWAYS, YOU KNOW,
CUT THE RIGHT WAY.
>> Shannon: WHERE WILL YOU GUYS
BE AT?
>> Ebony: MY BEDROOM.
>> Shannon: MY BELIEFS ON
HOMOSEXUALITY--I THINK
THAT DEFINITELY IT IS WRONG.
IT SAYS IN THE BIBLE THAT, UM,
IT'S AN ABOMINATION TO THE LORD.
>> Robin: I DON'T PERSONALLY,
LIKE, AGREE WITH IT.
>> Ebony: CAN YOU TELL ME
WHY YOU DON'T AGREE WITH IT?
>> Robin: I MEAN, JUST BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T AGREE WITH,
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW,
LESBIAN AND GAY RELATIONSHIPS,
BUT, I MEAN, I CAN'T JUDGE YOU.
>> Adrianne: THEY'RE SO
INNOCENT.
YOU KNOW, A GAY PERSON--
THEY'RE LIKE, "GAY! THAT'S
WRONG, WRONG, WRONG!"
I'M LIKE, "WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
SEE IN THIS INDUSTRY?
ARE YOU GONNA SIT THERE AND
PREACH TO THESE PEOPLE
AND TELL THEM THAT THEY'RE GONNA
BURN IN THE FIERY PITS OF HELL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GAY LOVER?"
>> Robin: IF IT'S NOT
IN MY ROOM OR IN THE ROOM
WHERE WE SLEEP--
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'--
THEN THAT'S FINE.
I JUST, YOU KNOW, LIKE,
I JUST DON'T WANT IT
IN OUR LIVING QUARTERS.
I CAN'T STOP HER, YOU KNOW,
FROM HAVING SOMEONE OVER.
EVERYBODY HAS TO DEAL
WITH THEIR OWN SINS.
>> Ebony: FABULOUS.
I UNDERSTAND. WE WORKIN' IT?
I'M TRYIN' TO WORK IT. OKAY?
♪♪♪
>> Ka: HI.
I'M HERE FOR EBONY.
>> Giselle: EBONY!
COME HITHER!
I HAVE SOMETHING TO ASK YOU.
HANG ON ONE SECOND.
>> Ebony: THE GIRLS KIND OF
TRICKED ME A LITTLE BIT.
I WAS INSIDE, YOU KNOW, GETTING
MY STUFF TOGETHER AND MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING WAS NEATED UP.
SO I COME OUT,
AND MY GIRLFRIEND KA, UM,
SHE'S HIDING BY THE DOOR.
YOU ARE SO CRAZY.
Y'ALL ARE SO CRAZY!
Y'ALL AIN'T CALLING ME
INTO THIS QUIET-ASS MEETING!
HI, SWEETIE.
I MIGHT AS WELL TAKE IT ALL OFF.
DO YOU SEE?
>> Ka: WOW.
>> Ebony: CAN YOU BELIEVE
I AM SO BALD?
>> Ka: YOU ARE... (laughing)
>> Ebony: THEY JACKED ME UP,
AND I HAD TO CUT
MY OWN DAMN HAIR.
I WAS LIKE, I DON'T GIVE A...
'CAUSE IT DON'T MATTER.
IT LOOK GOOD ANYWAY.
>> Ka: IT DOES.
>> Ebony: THE GIRLS WERE VERY
NICE.
YOU KNOW, THEY CAME AND
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES.
>> Giselle: WHERE'S THE
INTRODUCTION?
>> Ebony: I'M SORRY. THIS IS--
INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
>> Giselle: GISELLE.
>> Ka: KA.
>> Ebony: THIS IS KA.
>> Giselle: KA?
>> Ka: KA.
>> Ebony: THIS IS KESSE.
THEY GOIN' OUT PARTYIN'.
>> Elyse: IT SEEMED THAT ROBIN
AND SHANNON DIDN'T EVEN
WANT TO MEET KA.
THEY PRETTY MUCH STAYED
IN THE OTHER ROOM.
>> Adrianne: I HAVE SO MANY GAY
FRIENDS.
I DON'T CARE.
SHE'S REALLY, REALLY COOL,
AND SHE REALLY LOVES
HER GIRLFRIEND.
>> Ebony: WILD COLOR.
IT'S REALLY PRETTY.
AND THIS IS THE BOTTOM.
>> Ka: MM.
>> Elyse: I REALLY LIKED HER.
SHE WAS EXACTLY LIKE I EXPECTED.
UM, SHE OBVIOUSLY LOVED HER
A LOT.
>> Ka: OH, I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
>> Ebony: HAVING HER HERE WAS
GREAT.
YOU KNOW, IT REALLY LET ME KNOW
THAT SHE'S OKAY AND SHE'S
IN THIS FOR THE LONG RUN.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: WE HAD GOTTEN, UM,
A LETTER FROM, UM, TYRA.
>> Elyse: ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
"YOU HAVE A SHOOT TOMORROW.
BE READY TO GO IN THE MAIN ROOM
AT 8 A.M.
YOU WILL HAVE NO MAKEUP ON."
>> Adrianne: SWEET!
THEY BETTER DO MY HAIR.
>> Giselle: OUR LITTLE TYRA MAIL
SAID, "SHOOT IN THE MORNING."
WE'RE LIKE, "OKAY, PHOTO SHOOT."
AND WE WERE EXCITED.
SOME PEOPLE WERE NERVOUS.
♪♪♪
>> Elyse: BECAUSE OF
THE ACTING LESSONS THAT WE TOOK,
I KNEW THERE WAS GONNA BE
SOME KIND OF ACTING INVOLVED.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
>> Women: HI.
>> Tyra: HI. OKAY.
SO TODAY YOU GUYS ARE SHOOTING A
COMMERCIAL,
AND THE AMAZING THING
ABOUT COMMERCIALS FOR A MODEL
IS THAT ALMOST EVERYBODY
HAS A TV, SO THIS IS WHERE
YOUR STARDOM IS SOLIDIFIED.
THIS IS WHERE CINDY CRAWFORD,
CLAUDIA SCHIFFER AND MYSELF
GOT FAMOUS--
BY ENTERING PEOPLE'S HOMES,
BY ENTERING THAT TV.
WITH A COMMERCIAL,
IT'S LESS FORGIVING.
WITH PHOTO SHOOTS, IT'S SNAP.
YOU MESSED UP? OKAY, SNAP.
YOU MESSED UP AGAIN? OKAY, SNAP.
OKAY, THAT ONE'S PERFECT.
WITH THIS,
IT IS CONSTANT MOTION,
AND EVERY SINGLE FRAME
IN THIS FILM HAS TO BE PERFECT.
THIS IS YOUR DIRECTOR TODAY--
LOREN HAYNES.
HE IS YOUR SAVIOR.
THIS IS YOUR BEST FRIEND TODAY.
THIS IS THE PERSON
THAT YOU LISTEN TO.
HE KNOWS BEST.
>> Loren: SO THIS IS
A COMMERCIAL.
IT'S FOR CONTACT LENSES.
WE'VE GOT COPY.
THERE'S DIALOGUE.
AND YOU'VE GOTTA COME OUT.
WE'VE GOT MOVEMENT, ATTITUDE.
SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO HERE
IS GIVE YOU THE COPY.
THERE'S COPY ON THIS. YOU GUYS
HAVE TO LEARN IT.
>> Kesse: THE CHOREOGRAPHER TOOK
US OUTSIDE,
AND WE KINDA GOT THIS LITTLE
ROUTINE TOGETHER FOR THE
COMMERCIAL.
>> Tracy: 1, 2, 3 AND 4.
>> Kesse: COLOR IS POWER.
>> Tracy: A 1, 2, 3, 4.
>> Kesse: COLOR IS EMOTION.
>> Tracy: OOH!
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE
YOUR HAND HERE.
>> Kesse: YEAH, LEAVE IT--
JUST MOVE IT.
>> Tracy: YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO
ANYTHING, RIGHT?
>> Giselle: I'M LIKE,
"OKAY, LADY, I'VE BEEN
THE DANCER FOR 15 YEARS.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT," SO I KINDA GOT
A LITTLE COCKY THERE,
BUT I DIDN'T SHOW IT.
I WAS JUST THINKING IT,
AND I WAS LIKE, UGH.
♪♪♪
>> Shannon: THIS IS A HARD ONE.
>> Adrianne: ARE THOSE SILICONE?
>> Elyse: YEAH.
♪♪♪
>> Loren: ACTION.
>> Kesse: COLOR IS POWER.
NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS
WOULD I THINK I WOULD BE
DOING A COMMERCIAL,
WHICH WAS SO MUCH FUN.
COLOR IS EMOTION.
COLOR IS EXCITEMENT.
>> Loren: KESSE WAS GREAT
AND WONDERFUL, AND SHE TRIED,
AND SHE WORKED REALLY HARD,
AND HER PERSONALITY WAS THERE,
AND SHE, YOU KNOW,
WANTED TO MAKE IT WORK.
>> Man: FAST SPEED.
>> Loren: ACTION.
>> Elyse: COLOR IS INTRIGUE.
>> Loren: ELYSE HAD CHARACTER.
SHE HAD ENERGY.
SHE HAD SO MUCH LIKEABILITY,
AND NOTHING WAS FORCED.
>> Elyse: COLOR IS EMOTION.
COLOR IS PASSION.
COLOR IS EXCITEMENT.
IT WAS REALLY EMBARRASSING.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT
AND LAUGH AT IT.
>> Man: AND HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
>> Man #2: TAKE 1.
>> Shannon: AND FRESH COLOR
IS ONLY FOR YOUR EYES.
ONE LINE WAS A LITTLE BIT HARD
FOR ME.
I COULD NOT GET THE LINE DOWN.
I KEPT ON SAYING,
"AND FRESH COLOR
IS ONLY FOR YOUR EYES."
AND FRESH COLOR IS ONLY...
>> Loren: JUST THINK
THE WORD "COLOR."
"FRESH LOOK IS COLOR."
COLOR, COLOR, COLOR.
>> Shannon: I LEAST I GOT IT
RIGHT ONCE.
FRESH LOOK IS COLOR FOR YOUR
EYES.
>> Loren: I THINK SHANNON HAD
A TOUGH TIME WITH IT, WITH THE
DIALOGUE.
I THINK HER PERSONALITY AND SO
FORTH WAS GREAT,
AND SHE--YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SO MUCH THERE,
BUT THERE WAS JUST WORK AGAIN
JUST BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T HIT
THAT COPY.
GISELLE'S IN THE HOUSE.
>> Giselle: COLOR IS POWER.
THE DIRECTOR WAS LIKE,
"OKAY, I WANT YOU
TO FLIRT WITH THE CAMERA,
AND I WANT YOU TO BE SENSUOUS."
COLOR IS EMOTION.
>> Loren: FANTASTIC.
>> Giselle: I DID IT,
AND THE DIRECTOR LOVED IT.
PASSION.
>> Loren: GISELLE'S DOING GREAT.
SHE'S, UM, GREAT EMOTION,
GREAT ENERGY, PASSION.
SHE'S ABLE TO BRING A LOT
INTO THE FACE.
ACTION.
>> Adrianne: (Chicago accent)
PASSION. PASSION.
>> Loren: PASSION.
(imitates Chicago accent)
PASSION...(normal voice) TO
PASSION.
>> Adrianne: I'M FROM CHICAGO.
>> Loren: OKAY, WELL, LOSE IT.
>> Adrianne: I'M TRYING.
THEY WERE HAMMERIN' ME
FOR MY ACCENT,
AND I HAD TO SIT THERE AND TRY
NOT TO TALK LIKE A CHICAGOAN.
PASSION.
>> Loren: WITH ADRIANNE,
YOU KNOW, HAD A PROBLEM WITH HER
JUST NOT BEING ABLE TO LOSE
THE HOMEBOY ATTITUDE.
>> Adrianne: AM I SAYING IT
RIGHT, YO?
YOU GOTTA HELP ME OUT.
>> Loren: NOT EVEN CLOSE,
BUT LET'S--ONE MORE SHOT.
YOU GOT ONE MORE CHANCE AT IT.
>> Adrianne: PASSION.
>> Loren: OKAY.
YOU WERE CONSISTENT.
>> Man: ROLL SOUND. ROLL VIDEO.
ROLL DIGITAL.
>> Robin: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> Loren: CUT.
LET'S DO THAT AGAIN.
>> Robin: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> Loren: FANTASTIC. CUT.
SHE WAS GREAT.
I MEAN, HER FACE
WAS JUST BEAUTIFUL.
HER MOVEMENT WAS FANTASTIC.
SHE WAS VIRTUALLY A PRO.
>> Man: CAMERA READY?
>> Ebony: I'M VERY GOOD
AT SELLING PRODUCTS.
I'VE BEEN IN RETAIL ACTUALLY
SINCE I WAS 19.
I THINK WITH COMMERCIALS,
IT'S MORE OF SELLING THE
PRODUCT, YOU KNOW?
ARE YOU THE IMAGE THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL SELL THIS PRODUCT?
>> Man: ACTION.
>> Ebony: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> Loren: WHEN YOU WALK OUT
AND DO THAT THING,
TRY NOT TO DO THE HOP WITH YOUR
SHOES.
>> Ebony: GOT IT.
>> Loren: WE HEAR THAT
CLICK-CLICK CLATTER, OKAY?
AS WE GOT INTO THE TOUGHER SHOT
WHERE SHE HAD TO GET
THE MOVEMENT, THE DIALOGUE
AND THE STEPS, SHE GOT NERVOUS
AND SHE COULDN'T QUITE
HOLD ON TO IT.
>> Man: 4, 3, 2, ACTION.
>> Ebony: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> Loren: SHE FORGET ALL
THE STEPS THAT SHE HAD LEARNED
FROM THE CHOREOGRAPHER
AND COULDN'T QUITE, YOU KNOW,
GET IT IN THERE.
>> Ebony: AND FRESH COLOR...
AND FRESH LOOK IS COLOR...
>> Loren: YOUR LAST TAKE ON
THAT.
THANK YOU, EBONY.
>> Man: 3, 2, 1. ACTION.
>> Women: FRESH LOOK.
BEAUTIFUL EYES.
>> Loren: AND WE CUT.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: "TOMORROW'S INTERVIEW
WILL BE, UM, CONTINUING ON
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
>> Adrianne: GOOD!
>> Elyse: WHEN I FIRST MET
EBONY, I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
SHE WOULD WIN THE COMPETITION,
BUT, UM, TODAY AT THE COMMERCIAL
SHE DIDN'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB
MEMORIZING HER LINES.
I THINK THE BIGGEST LIMITATION
TO GISELLE AS A MODEL IS GISELLE
AND HER, UM, DISCOMFORT AROUND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CRITICIZING HER.
>> Giselle: I'M REALLY NERVOUS
ABOUT OUR NEXT ELIMINATION.
I HAVE A GUT, GUT, GUT FEELING
THAT IT'LL BE MY TURN TO GO.
WHEN SHANNON CAME BACK IN
FROM HER SHOOT,
SHE GOT KINDA FRUSTRATED.
>> Shannon: YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG YOU HAVE IN THIS HOUSE,
SO YOU BETTER BE PREPARED.
I REALLY, REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY WANT THIS.
>> Ebony: WE ALL HAVE
THIS ULTIMATE DREAM,
AND NO MATTER HOW MUCH
PEOPLE MIGHT SAY,
"I DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS, I
DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS,"
I KNOW THAT THEY CARE, YOU KNOW?
AND, UM, I'M JUST
AS SCARED AS THEM.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: WELCOME, LADIES.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER EXCITING WEEK
IN YOUR JOURNEY TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A REVLON CONTRACT, A CONTRACT
WITH WILHELMINA MODELS, INC.
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE."
ONCE AGAIN, WE HAVE
OUR PANEL OF EXPERT JUDGES.
OUR EXPERT JUDGES ARE HERE
TO EVALUATE YOU
ON THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODELS.
NEXT, WE HAVE BEAU QUILLIAN.
BEAU QUILLIAN IS THE FASHION
EDITOR AT "MARIE CLAIRE."
WE HAVE KIMORA LEE SIMMONS.
SHE'S THE OWNER AND CREATIVE
DIRECTOR OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST.
THIS WEEK'S JUDGE IS
YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR
LOREN HAYNES.
NOW THIS WEEK YOU GUYS
HAVE ENTERED A NEW ARENA
IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
YOU'RE NOT JUST POSING
STIFF LIKE MANNEQUINS.
YOU ACTUALLY FILMED
A TELEVISION COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE IT IS.
>> Robin: COLOR IS POWER.
>> Giselle: COLOR IS EMOTION.
>> Ebony: COLOR IS EXCITEMENT.
>> Shannon: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> Elyse: COLOR IS INTRIGUE.
>> Adrianne: ADVENTURE.
(Chicago accent) PASSION.
>> Kesse: AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
>> All: FRESH LOOK,
BEAUTIFUL EYES.
>> Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATION,
AND, SHANNON, YOU'RE FIRST.
>> Loren: OKAY, SHANNON,
WE'RE GONNA DO A COLD READING,
OKAY?
SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU THE
SCRIPT.
YOU HAVE A FEW MINUTES TO LOOK
AT IT, AND THEN SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE DID YESTERDAY, OKAY?
SO WE'RE SORT OF CREATING AN
AUDITION SITUATION.
READY? OKAY, ACTION.
>> Shannon: HEY!
COME HERE.
>> Kesse: YES, YOU.
>> Ebony: SEE THIS SUPER SEXY
SMILE?
>> Adrianne: KNOW HOW I KEEP IT
LOOKING SO GREAT?
>> Elyse: WATER.
IT HAS A SPECIAL
TEETH WHITENING FORMULA...
>> Giselle: TO KEEP
MY PEARLY WHITES ALL RIGHT. NO.
>> Robin: AND THE TASTE--
LIKE REFRESHING CRYSTAL
SNOWFLAKES FALLING ON
A SPARKLING, SNOW-COVERED
MOUNTAIN.
WATER.
>> Elyse: WATER.
>> Shannon: WATER.
>> Kesse: WATER.
>> Adrianne: WATER.
>> Giselle: WATER.
>> Ebony: WA--
WATER.
>> Janice: OKAY.
>> Tyra: OKAY.
I THINK THAT YOUR LOOK
IS SO WELCOMING, YOU KNOW?
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO TV,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT BE
TOO INTIMIDATING ON TV,
'CAUSE YOU HAVE TO REACH
A BROAD AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
>> Janice: IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
LANDED FROM ANOTHER PLANET,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SO MUCH TEETH.
THE TEETH THING--YOU GOTTA KINDA
REALLY WORK ON THAT BREAKING
INTO THE BIG GRIN THING.
>> Tyra: I HAVE A BIG SMILE,
TOO, AND A LOT OF TEETH,
LIKE JUST, UHH.
WHEN I SMILE NATURALLY,
MY TOP LIP GOES AWAY.
YOU HAVE TO PRACTICE THAT
IN THE MIRROR.
(through teeth) THERE'S THIS
AND THEN THERE'S THIS.
(normal voice) OKAY?
>> Kimora: YOU REALLY WEREN'T
SCARED OF IT, AND YOU DIDN'T
GIVE IT TOO MUCH, AND YOU
REALLY GOT THE SEXY THING.
>> Loren: THE CAMERA LOVES YOU,
AND YOU WORKED IT.
YOU WORKED THAT CAMERA
BEAUTIFULLY.
>> Kesse: THANKS.
>> Janice: I THINK THAT
THE COMMERCIAL WAS GREAT.
YOU'VE GOT A KILLER SMILE.
>> Robin: YES, MA'AM.
>> Janice: KIND OF LOOSEN UP
AND NOT BE SO PAGEANTRY
STANDING IN FRONT OF US.
>> Robin: YES, MA'AM.
>> Janice: I DON'T LIKE
WHEN YOU CALL ME "MA'AM."
I THINK IT'S CONDESCENDING.
JUST SIT THERE AND JUST SAY,
YOU KNOW, "OKAY."
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY,
"YES, SIR. NO, SIR.
YES, MA'AM. NO, MA'AM."
IT'S NOT A PAGEANT.
>> Tyra: IF SHE WINS THIS
CONTEST, IS SHE GONNA GO,
"THANK YOU. THANK YOU"?
JUST PULL BACK A LITTLE BIT,
ALL RIGHT?
>> Loren: ROBIN, ONE MORE THING.
>> Robin: YES, SIR.
>> Loren: YOU CAN CALL ME
"MA'AM" ANYTIME.
>> Tyra: AAH! WHOO!
>> Kimora: WHEN YOU TALK,
IT MAKES ME WANNA GRIT MY TEETH.
>> Loren: MY BIGGEST PROBLEM
I HAD WITH YOU IS THAT
ONE WORD--"PASSION."
>> Tyra: THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT YOU CAN READ THE SAME LINE.
I'LL DO IT FOR YOU.
I MEAN, "TYRA, GIVE ME SEXY."
(sexy voice) PASSION.
(normal voice) "TYRA,
GIVE IT TO ME SOFT."
(softly) PASSION.
(normal voice) "TYRA, GIVE IT TO
ME EXCITED."
PASSION.
>> Loren: I WAS WORRIED ABOUT
THE SPOT.
THEN WE GET TO THE CLOSE-UPS.
BOY, DID YOUR FACE
AND YOUR EYES CARRY IT.
>> Beau: IT'S
YOUR SELF-CONFIDENCE AGAIN.
I'M STILL SEEING
A LITTLE BIT OF A LACK OF IT.
>> Giselle: ACTUALLY,
I THOUGHT YESTERDAY BOOSTED
MY SELF-CONFIDENCE A LOT MORE.
>> Kimora: I THOUGHT
YOU WERE GREAT. UM...
>> Giselle: YOU ALWAYS HAVE
SOMETHING NICE TO SAY.
>> Kimora: NOT ALWAYS.
I'M THE DEVIL ON THE BOARD.
>> Loren: I DID NOT KNOW
YOU WERE A DANCER, AND IF I DID,
I WOULD HAVE PUSHED YOU
A LOT HARDER YESTERDAY.
I'M SORT OF SHOCKED AT THAT.
>> Tyra: GIVE THEM ALL THE
GOODS.
I CAN KICK. I CAN SPIN.
I CAN TWIRL.
I CAN STAND ON MY HEAD.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
>> Janice: I THINK THAT WAS
THE WORST READING I'VE EVER--
I'VE EVER HEARD.
I MEAN, HOW LONG HAVE YOU
WANTED TO BE A MODEL?
THE READING SUCKED, I'M SORRY.
>> Ebony: OKAY.
>> Tyra: AND THEN AS FAR AS
THE COMMERCIAL, I THOUGHT
YOU LOOKED SO BEAUTIFUL.
THE CONTACTS LOOKED GREAT.
BUT IT JUST SEEMED
A LITTLE STILTED.
>> Loren: WE HAD TO WORK
A LONG TIME ON YOUR SPOT
TO GET THIS.
>> Beau: I SEE
THAT YOU KEEP THE LENSES.
>> Kimora: OR YOU STOLE THEM
LIKE A REAL TOP MODEL.
(laughter)
>> Tyra: THERE WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF QUIRKINESS
THAT WASN'T WORKING,
BUT EVERY NOW AND THEN
IT WOULD WORK,
LIKE A CERTAIN GIGGLE,
AND A CERTAIN KIND
OF AWKWARDNESS THAT KIND OF
PLAYED IN YOUR FAVOR.
>> Beau: I AGREE WITH TYRA.
THERE WERE MOMENTS
THAT IT WORKED, AND THERE WERE
MOMENTS THAT IT KIND OF SEEMED
LIKE YOU WERE
A LITTLE MARIONETTE DOLLY
THAT HAD HER STRINGS CUT.
>> Janice: ELYSE,
YOU'VE GOTTA PRACTICE!
>> Elyse: ANYTHING ELSE?
>> Tyra: THANKS, ELYSE.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: LET'S START WITH ELYSE.
ELYSE WAS SO AWKWARD
IN HER COMMERCIAL.
IT WAS UNCANNY, BUT I THINK
IT DID WORK FOR HER.
>> Janice: BUT SHE HAS WHAT IT
TAKES
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED TO STAY
IN THE COMPETITION TODAY.
>> Tyra: ADRIANNE.
>> Janice: SHE HAS TO
TAKE SPEECH CLASSES
TO WORK THE MOUTH THING.
>> Kimora: I DON'T THINK
THAT HER SMILE'S GONNA GET HER--
I'M NOT IMPRESSED BY HER.
>> Loren: SHE BRINGS
HER OWN NATURAL QUALITY,
BUT THE DIRECTION--AGAIN,
THE KEY WAS THE VOICE, TOO.
I MEAN, THERE WERE
SO MANY LIMITATIONS, I THINK,
THAT SHE HAS.
SHE TRIED, BUT NOT A NATURAL.
>> Tyra: KESSE.
>> Beau: THERE'S SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT PEDESTRIAN ABOUT
HER.
>> Tyra: I THOUGHT KESSE
IN THE COMMERCIAL--I WAS
JUST FLOORED BY HOW BEAUTIFUL
SHE LOOKED IN THE COMMERCIAL.
>> Kimora: I THINK SHE
CONSTANTLY SHOWS IMPROVEMENT,
AND I KNOW THAT'S A BIG FACTOR
HERE.
>> Tyra: ROBIN.
>> Janice: I CAN'T GET OVER
THE "YES, MA'AM, NO, MA'AM"
PAGEANT QUEEN.
>> Tyra: I THINK ROBIN IS
BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK SHE REPRESENTS AMERICA.
I THINK SHANNON
COULD BE AMERICA'S SWEETHEART.
SHE JUST NEEDS
TO WORK ON HER SEXUALITY,
AND SHE NEEDS TO WORK ON
KNOWING HOW TO WORK HER SMILE
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
JANICE?
>> Janice: YEAH, I AGREE.
THERE ARE SO MANY TEETH
IN HER MOUTH.
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE, MAYBE SHE
SHOULD HAVE A FEW REMOVED.
>> Tyra: EBONY.
>> Janice: I'M KIND OF WANING ON
EBONY.
>> Tyra: BEAU?
>> Beau: I THOUGHT
SHE BLOSSOMED IN FRONT
OF THE TELEVISION CAMERA.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS SO FANTASTIC,
BUT HER PERFORMANCE ALL IN ALL
HAS BEEN SO UP AND DOWN,
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT.
>> Kimora: I AGREE WITH BEAU.
I THINK THAT EBONY IS--FOR ME,
PERSONALLY,
SHE HAS A HARSHNESS,
LIKE A ROUGH EDGE.
>> Loren: BUT THEN THE MINUTE
SHE OPENS HER MOUTH WITH A SMILE
IT JUST WARMS UP
AND IT GOES AWAY FOR ME.
I FELT YESTERDAY THAT SHE WAS
REALLY WORKING HARD,
BUT I FELT INTERNALLY
IT WAS JUST PAINING--
YOU KNOW, IT WAS A PAIN TO HER
THAT, "GOD, I HAVE TO DO THIS."
>> Tyra: NOW THERE'S GISELLE.
BEAU?
>> Beau: WELL, WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO GISELLE ABOUT
SELF-CONFIDENCE FROM THE GET-GO,
AND SHE'S NOT BEHIND HERSELF.
YOU KNOW, NOBODY'S EVER GONNA
BOOK HER WITH AN ATTITUDE
LIKE THAT.
>> Loren: SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
AND SHE HAS A NATURAL--
A NATURAL ENERGY AND SEXUALITY.
>> Janice: I THINK THAT
HER INSECURITY
REALLY CAME THROUGH TODAY.
WE'RE ALL INSECURE TO A POINT.
OTHERS MASK IT BETTER.
>> Loren: WHETHER SHE CAN
BREAK AWAY FROM THAT--
I THINK THAT'S SORT OF
THE QUESTION WITH HER.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: THIS ELIMINATION
PROCESS GETS
TOUGHER AND TOUGHER EACH WEEK,
BUT SOMEBODY HAS TO GO HOME,
AND THE JUDGES HAVE REACHED
THEIR DECISION.
>> Ebony: MY SPIRIT IS
TELLING ME, "YOU MUST JUST BE
THE BEST YOU CAN BE," YOU KNOW,
AND NOT THINK NEGATIVELY.
>> Giselle: IT'S ANOTHER
STRESSFUL DAY,
AND I'M JUST WORRIED THAT
I'M GONNA GET ELIMINATED.
>> Tyra: THERE ARE SEVEN OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
THESE SIX PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE WOMEN THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KESSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> Kesse: THANK YOU.
>> Tyra: ELYSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> Elyse: THANK YOU.
>> Tyra: (through teeth)
ADRIANNE,
WE THINK YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
(laughter)
>> Tyra: WE THINK
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
THE BANGS WERE GORGEOUS.
BUT YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL I'M SAYING
RIGHT NOW, AND HALF THE TIME
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
YOU'RE SAYING, EITHER.
(normal voice) SO OPEN
YOUR MOUTH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Tyra: ROBIN.
ROBIN, YOU ARE FULL
OF CONFIDENCE.
THIS ISN'T MISS AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT MISS U.S.A.
THERE ARE NO SASHES ON ANYBODY.
YOU ARE NOT
(Southern accent) MISS TENNESSEE
(normal voice) IN THIS
COMPETITION.
IN FACT, TOP MODELS
HATE BEAUTY QUEENS
BECAUSE WE'RE CONSTANTLY
GETTING COMPARED TO THEM,
AND I AIN'T NO BEAUTY QUEEN.
>> Janice: (laughing)
>> Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Tyra: SHANNON.
YOU GOT THOSE BEAUTIFUL
PEARLY WHITES.
AS FAR AS OBSESSING OVER LINES,
THEY'RE JUST LINES.
RELAX.
JUST LET IT GO.
BUT WHAT I DON'T WANT YOU
TO LET GO IS YOUR SENSUALITY
AND YOUR SEXUALITY.
IT'S THERE.
JUST BECAUSE YOU AIN'T
DONE IT YET DON'T MEAN DONE IT,
DON'T MEAN THAT'S IT NOT THERE.
NOBODY JUST WANTS TO LOOK AT...
"HI!"
YOU KNOW, NOBODY WANTS
TO LOOK AT THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL GISELLE AND EBONY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> Tyra: I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
WHOEVER RECEIVES IT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THE OTHER YOUNG LADY
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE PENTHOUSE
AND PACK YOUR BAGS AND GO HOME.
>> Tyra: GISELLE,
EVEN AS YOU STAND HERE RIGHT NOW
IT'S LIKE,
WHERE'S THE SELF-ESTEEM?
YOU EVER BEEN TO A CLUB,
AND YOU SEE A GIRL THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE MOST ATTRACTIVE
GIRL IN THAT CLUB,
BUT ALL THE GUYS IN THE CLUB
WANT HER, AND YOU'RE LIKE, WHY?
THE REASON WHY
THEY ALL WANT HER IS BECAUSE
SHE BELIEVES SHE IS
THAT FINEST GIRL IN THAT CLUB.
EBONY...
YOU ARE BEAUTIFUL.
AND YOUR SMILE IS BREATHTAKING,
BUT YOU HAVE--
WHEN YOU COME INTO THE ROOM,
WE SENSE
A CHIP ON YOUR SHOULDER,
A TYPE OF ANGER THAT MAKES YOU
PUSH YOURSELF TOO HARD
TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU LOSE FOCUS
AND YOU BECOME DIFFICULT
TO WORK WITH.
>> Tyra: GISELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, EBONY.
>> Giselle: WHOA,
SHE JUST WALKED OUT
WITHOUT EVEN SAYING ANYTHING.
THAT SUCKS,
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T SAY GOOD-BYE.
>> Ebony: HI. IT'S ME.
I NEED YOU TO CALL...
YOU NEVER KNOW HOW YOU'RE GONNA
FEEL AFTER SOMETHING, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT TO YOU
UNTIL IT HAPPENS.
IT'S MORE OF JUST--
JUST THE WORDS THAT WERE SAID.
YOU KNOW, UM, TYRA SAID
IT SEEMED AS THOUGH I WAS
A LITTLE ANGRY ABOUT SOMETHING,
AND, UM, I THINK THAT WAS
MORE HURTFUL, BECAUSE, UM,
ALMOST LIKE SHE COULDN'T SEE
HOW HAPPY I WAS TO BE THERE.
♪♪♪
Stay tuned for scenes from our
next episode.
Here's what's coming up on
America's Next Top Model.
Grease me like you're my momma!
The girls sex it up for the
camera
And Elyse's health, become's an
issue.
Cuz she looks at herself in the
mirror and she, does like
this...
I've never had an eating problem
This girl is killing herself
(crying) I hate it here